et on dirait que dans ce journal
stéphane caillet médecins infectiologues
au chru de strasbourg bonjour stéphane
caillet merci d'être avec nous sur arte
france le port du masque est obligatoire
donc depuis ce matin à 8 heures dans les
rues de strasbourg votre ville c'est
dans de nombreuses villes alsaciennes
qui emboîte le pas à paris ou à
marseille prévention justifier ou
alarmisme disproportionnée c'est une
vaste question
le masque est une barrière à sceptiques
qui a fait largement la preuve de son
efficacité depuis la fin du 19e siècle
dans les milieux de soins au bloc
opératoire dans les salles de soins et
puis également dans l'agroalimentaire
site une barrière à sceptiques qui
fonctionne bien
autant le masque à une intérêt
incontestable lorsque l'on se situe à
l'intérieur des locaux et lorsque l'on
se trouve à courte distance moins d'un
mètre cinquante
mais lorsque l'on se trouve à l'air
extérieur
il y a toujours du vent il y a toujours
des courants d'air il y a une très forte
dispersion de toutes les particules que
l'on aimé aussi bien des
microgouttelettes qui sont en fait des
aérosols humide que et des particules
aéroportée qu'on appelle aérosols sec ou
depuis quelques temps et russell tout
court c'est à dire que lorsque l'on se
trouve à l'extérieur
et lorsque l'on est mobile par exemple
lorsque l'on marche et a fortiori
lorsque l'on se déplace à vélo toutes
les particules pouvant contenir des
virus que l'on aimé sont immédiatement
dispersées
ils ne peuvent pas atteindre leur cible
c'est-à-dire l'euro pharynx d'une
personne il suffit par exemple de
prendre le tabagisme ou leva potage
quand on est à l'intérieur des locaux
lorsque l'on se trouve à courte distance
d'une personne qui fument ou qui va
potes mais surtout d'une personne qui
fume et bien on est facilement incommodé
parce qu on inhale très rapidement le la
fumée de tabac qui était mise ces
principes du tabagisme passif mais à
l'extérieur on n'a jamais entendu une
personne se plaindre du tabagisme passif
ça n'existe pas ni du bape otages il
suffit de regarder la fumée
elle s'envole tout de suite elle
disparaît et c'est une décision
politique par exemple la maire
écologiste de strasbourg votre ville
j'aime marseille on conteste cette
décision
comment se positionne la communauté
scientifique par rapport à cette
décision
la grande majorité des épidémiologistes
et des hygiénistes pense que c'est une
mesure qui n'est pas justifié c'était le
port du masque à l'extérieur j'insiste
pour des personnes mobiles s'il s'agit
de personnes qui sont très proches les
unes des autres et immobile et qu'il n'y
a pas de vent mais vraiment très proche
c'est-à-dire à 50 cm là dans ce cas là
il peut y avoir un risque et je pense en
effet que la décision qui est prise de
rendre le masque obligatoire à
l'extérieur et c'est une c'est une
décision qui correspond à une inquiétude
parce que les pouvoirs publics
voyant le nombre n'ont pas de cas mais
deux porteurs du virus augmenté du fait
de l'augmentation des prélèvements et
bien prennent peur et on se disent on va
fermer les vannes on va fermer les
robinets
on va réduire encore la circulation du
virus en obligeant le port du masque à
l'extérieur mais en effet c'est une
décision qui correspond à une stratégie
politique mais qui n'a pas vraiment de
justification sur le plan
épidémiologique et je pense qu'elle peut
être contre-productive
parce que ça contribue et on le voit à
agacer les gens parce que tout
simplement beaucoup d'avis
d'épidémiologistes commencent à se faire
entendre et le grand public commence à
savoir que cette mesure a énormément de
balles à être justifié alors justement
comment est-ce que vous réagissez à ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui on a vu
aujourd'hui à paris une manifestation
anti masque manifestation d'ampleur
également à berlin 18 mille personnes
dans les rues mobilisation actuellement
à londres qui
à lui encore comment est-ce que vous
analysez ce scepticisme encore marginale
mais conditions autour du port du masque
et comment est ce que vous vous
réagissez à toutes ces manifestations
anti masque aujourd'hui mais on a
entendu les les points de vue sont
diverses et variées il ya des gens qui
parlent d'une atteinte à la liberté
il ya des gens qui évoquent la
difficulté de d'inspirer tout simplement
il est de fait que lorsqu'il pleut et
que l'on porte un masque et bien on peut
éprouver des difficultés respiratoires
ces manifestations traduisent un
agacement
beaucoup de gens sent bien que c'est une
mesure qui est excessive et qu'on a du
mal de justifier et vous condamnent ces
manifestations ou pas parce que ces
rassemblements de masse de masse sans
masque sans distanciation sociale est ce
que c'est pas non plus finalement
décontamination des foyers de
contamination en puissance alors qu'on
sait le le
la circulation du virus est bien les
juges est exponentielle un parent santé
publique france bon en fait très
honnêtement c'est
ça résulte de tests viraux virologique
que l'on effectué et on détecte beaucoup
de porteurs qui sont asymptomatiques ou
pour aussi symptomatique c'est à dire
qu'ils sont très peu malade alors elle
s'agissant des rassemblements oui
évidemment c'est préjudiciable puisque
lorsque les gens et sont immobiles ous
ne se déplacent pratiquement pas et qui
sont proches les uns des autres
là dans ce cas là on réunit les
conditions qui vont permettre une
circulation des virus
d'un côté bon je comprends le sentiment
qui anime ces gens qui veulent se
révolter contre mesures difficiles à
justifier mais en effet d'un autre côté
ces rassemblements peuvent permettre au
contraire une circulation du virus dans
la mesure où les personnes sont très
proches les unes des autres
tout à fait merci stéphane gagné d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin infectiologue au csa
rue de strasbourg